what was once a race thing isn't a race
thing anymore it's a need for LA to be
more developed for you know for everyone
my name is Lourdes I am 20 years old and
I am a student my name is Terrence I'm
transplant and I work currently for
security at LAX I'm Dominique right I'm
32 and I don't know what my employee
status is so I can't really tell you
about that in like the purest most of
still the form of that question I would
definitely agree right that if you are
able to if somewhere and you you know
are willing to live there and not just
you know because I think there's a
difference between it's not like freedom
of speech you you can say whatever you
want but there are negative connotations
that could happen from you saying
something just last if you move
somewhere there could possibly be
damaging effects even though you have no
ill intent at all something could happen
where you moved in here all your homies
and friends move there and everyone's
here now and then the people were there
first can't even go I think what I
perceived in that question was just like
your absolute mobility and moving like
wherever you want without like the
repercussions of like for say you're
moving into this space that has a lot of
history and you're
is like could be possibly oppressive to
the pre-existing community I wasn't sure
cuz I still live in the place I grew up
so my hometown is in Massachusetts which
is very different from Los Angeles and
so I miss some of the seasonal things
about it for sure yeah we don't have
never get winters or Falls like we do up
there the town where I grew up my
parents only live chose that place
because the taxes were really high there
but it all went to like the good school
systems when my sister and I left they
sold the house and I know it's hard for
my sister because we can't really go
back home in that sense
I'd say living in Echo Park my whole
life you while I'm living there I see it
changing right before my eyes and it's
this like weird weird experience where
you see the people you grew up with
saying oh I can't afford this right I'm
I have to move over like 30 miles away
and I think that's one major thing that
gentrification does and that's it really
makes people lose their sense of like
belonging and community building and to
uproot people it's me being nomadic in
nature I'm a military kid I've grown up
in so many different places it's not
where I grew up it's who was there most
of my family has moved and most of my
friends have moved away from where I
grew up in Michigan also I kind of grew
up in a very bad neighborhood it wasn't
the greatest the high school like doing
- wasn't the greatest so it's hard when
I go back there and then I see those
things I'm reminded of how I grew up I
totally hear that and
being from central Pennsylvania and I
never really feel felt like I belong
there from whenever I was very young you
know I feel like Pennsylvania made me
but la really made me you know like I'm
from there but I feel like this is where
I became Who I am
there are things about the city that I
love like I would not want to die
anywhere else but there are so many
things that have changed in the city so
just imagine being 30 and seeing people
that you grew up with not being able to
afford apartment on a street where the
rent shouldn't be no more than $1,200 I
guess I haven't been away for a long
period of time to say I miss it just
because I'm just in it every single day
El Morocco yeah I think it is I'm
joining you the almighty dollar has
erased our history and we have to we
have to preserve it or we're going to
just repeat the same here exactly we
learn from history
exactly so how are we gonna move forward
in a society if we don't recognize our
history exactly you know you see like a
city like Detroit right where Matt it's
his city has so much history especially
with the us's economy took a city that
was so bustling to somewhere where there
are many parts of the city's that I hear
like no man's land with with
reinvigoration I think also comes job
opportunities you know it keeps the
community that like up and moving and
bustling you just have to find your
space I grew up in Michigan it's like a
family from Detroit like that's real
like Motown is like my roots like they
still have like museums there that are
set up the Fox Theater like I still
remember going there as a kid like like
it's it's amazing like being there like
it's so crazy so how would you feel that
they tore that down them it'd be like
someone taking a piece of my heart and
just like put it on the floor like for
real
they're trying to tear down the Crenshaw
mall and make it to be like The Grove
which i think is
you don't need another a terrible idea
just because the people that are living
in that that area they're not gonna be
able to afford luxury loss doesn't go
cater to the pre-existing community I
have to say I have to disagree his I
actually work a lot in that area so I
work with people who flip houses and I
think it depends who's who in that area
you're speaking to because you know I
mean a lot of owners in that area and
for them they're loving it yeah and you
know but also some renters because now
it's becoming more walkable what was
once a race thing isn't a race thing
anymore it's a need for LA to be more
developed for you know for everyone I
don't think you need it deserve for sure
every child growing up to the adult
deserves to have something called home
but for me home is here it's not like
down the block on 31st it's just like
where I'm at that's home some people
want to move around or don't mind it or
if I actually take something good from
it but other people are very comfortable
and where they are I think it can be a
state of mind a state of being or I
think home absolutely is a feeling more
than a location and I think it's
something that evolves to different
stages of life I have moved from one and
then kind of found one again when I went
to college and then now I'm just yeah
I'm wondering like I'm realizing I have
to build it you know I think that the
word deserve is is tough because you
know I think that people deserve what
they create for themselves there are
some people who are just dealt a bad
hand
and that that is not included in this if
you're not putting in as much work as I
am why do you deserve the same thing
that I have unfortunately a lot of
people don't have the same knowledge are
the same empathy you might have so not
saying it's your job or it's your duty
with sometimes because that person may
not have that knowledge what you might
tell them might be able to be the spark
to change their mentality so they can go
out there and do what you should yes
what they deserve to have something well
you feel like you don't have anything
you know most of the time you are
they're gonna do something bad or you
and hurt yourself see some people take
that and they use that to become
something even bigger and better and
that's great I mean yeah but a lot of
people don't know how to do that if
someone's parent doesn't teach them
those things why is it then your
responsibility to pick up for the
parents that's not it this is more of a
moral thing well here's my thing like I
feel like home looks so different to
everybody
how does someone else having a home
really affect mine at all like like I'm
trying to think about like people just
need the basic necessities like I'm not
saying every person needs a force or
hi-rise like like I think that it's
possible that everyone has some sort of
home stability some kind of starting
point and then everyone else can go from
there I don't see why this should be an
issue about someone struggling just to
live in their own place like I don't I
don't not making that correlation and I
don't know maybe that's just me and I
might not be as versed in the economic
and housing market is you but I don't
see why every single person should not
be able to be inside somewhere I think
we as a whole have gotten away from
empathy and have latched on to apathy
because it's easy to say well I did it
so you can do it no but and I know
people down different situations and
they come with different weights on
their shoulders and whatnot but I also I
think that really the issue that
everybody's kind of touching on
that everyone deserves education
everyone deserves to know what they can
do and how they can arm themselves to to
be able to you know be have a home and
to create more I think that it's
important for people to take
responsibility for the direction that
their life takes you know once you
decide to do that and it stops speak it
stops being about what's happening to
you and instead what you're doing you
know it can change everything for you we
have to be mindful that apathy is
roaming the streets right now and it's
ready to kill everybody we have to get
it away from us and make sure that we
put goodness and kindness in our heart
and we're able to express that and give
to others
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys this is John from Jubilee
thanks for watching this episode of
middle ground we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below and also
what other topics you'd like to see in
an episode of middle ground please be
sure to click Subscribe and remember to
live greater